Today
we are making
our own
table tennis rackets
with
$1
$100
and $1000
budgets!
And have four challenges
to decide
whose racket is the best!
Will money make a difference?
Let's find out!
OK, it's time to decide
who gets which budget
So each balloon
has a certain amount of money
and when it explodes
we'll find out
how much is in it!
You got yourself
100€!
I'm happy with that budget!
BOOOOM!!
1000€!
I have no idea
what I'm going to do
with one 1€...
I think it's time to go
build our rackets!
OK, so I got 1000€
to spend on my racket
So obviously
we're going to get some diamonds!
I'm looking for diamonds
for a ping pong racket
Oh!
That sounds cool!
This is...
90,000€
Let's have a look at these smaller ones then...
Perfect!
Maybe if I get
a lot of these
small diamonds?
An additional rule
to building the racket is:
that you're not allowed to use
any real table tennis products
I wonder how Otto is doing
with his 1€?
Found the trash
Some cardboard
This is looking interesting!
Hardwood floor
Is there something
I could do with this?
Still would need to find
some kind of rubber
My budget:
100€
I did some plans...
My challenge is going to be:
You have to do
the maximum
amount of ball bounces
with the racket bottom!
So obviously I have to
come up with a racket
that has a wide bottom!
So let's head inside!
This is probably a bit too wide?
The next step would be to find
kind of like the shaft
Not really into that one
No...
This is the coolest handle that
you have ever seen
on a table tennis racket
I'm gonna have
some Jedi powers
against Miikka and Otto
Maybe?
This shopping center
looks expensive!
The racket has to be gold
This could be the perfect blade
It's not only a cake server
it's a FINE cake server!
I'm looking for
golden sheet
on a...
table tennis racket!
*Calls security*
It's not real gold
unfortunately
because they didn't have it
But it's going to be the most
beautiful racket!
And that's why my challenge
is gonna be:
A beauty contest!
So we're going to let
you guys vote
Who has the prettiest racket
And obviously
Otto's and Emil's
ugly cheap rackets
won't stand a chance!
We're gonna go
and look for a blacksmith
We can do a lot of stuff with this
You can even see through it
which is pretty cool
We need some rubber for the
for the racket!
This is the one
that we're looking for
Anti-slip mat!
Let's take this one and...
head towards the
working space!
My challenge is going to be:
To catch a ball
that is being hit
straight at you!
So...
If this would be my handle
Then I will put this
somewhere here!
Could I even
put another part there?
So I have this rubber mat
I'm gonna
put a piece of it
on the bottom
The new Sensei racket?
Going live on
This is gonna be the blade
And this is gonna be
the rubbers!
Is it going to be a good racket?
What do you think?
Of course
it's going to be a great racket!
This is one of the perks
of winning the 1000€ budget:
You don't have to build it yourself!
I have to be pretty careful
when I'm playing with that
I'm gonna cut
two parts of this
And then we put them together
It's going to be something magical!
One
out of two!
We're gonna round the edges a bit
That's so satisfying
We need
still a few more screws
So let's not screw this up!
This is gonna look so nice!
Back to the headquarters!
Now it's time to
reveal the rackets!
I'll go get my racket!
Let's see what
the Sensei has brought!
THIS
IS
MY
RACKET!
That's a chair!
It's a table tennis racket!
Can't you see?
It looks like...
from Robo wars or something!
Very good engineering
It's super solid!
How did you spend your budget?
1€
I still have my
whole budget to use!
It looks like
you have spent 0€ on this
Yeah, thank you!
No offense!
Are you guys ready
for the next one?
The 100€ budget?
Yes, we're ready for it!
Let's go!
Who is that?
What is that!?
He's made a lightsaber!
Is this absolutely necessary?
Emil's challenge is like:
Bounce with the bottom of the racket
or something!
It's looking good
I have to say!
The lightsaber part
That was
The rubber
Total budget?
Like 80€!
OK guys
are you ready for mine?
World's most expensive
table tennis racket!
What is it?
to help us make even crazier videos :)
Pongfinity Gold racket!
WOW!
That's impressive!
Real diamonds!
No way!
Really?
You can barely see them!
It's the shape
of a diamond
if you turn it around!
OK, so let's break down
the costs:
The rest
me and the racket
decided to treat ourselves!
How did you treat the racket?
Let's do the challenges!
You guessed it
absolutely right!
You just bounce!
I'm not feeling too confident
about this
One try
I think it was three!
I'll use this one
That's zero?
I was trying this
after I made this
and it's actually very difficult!
No...
No, no, no, no!
Wasn't that against the rules?
Was it?
No
There we go!
Yeah, that's enough Emil!
No need to show off
We know you have the best
racket bottom out of all three
I'll take the lead
So let's move on
to my challenge!
A ball catch!
Are you going to smash it
at me?
Yeah
Catch it
without any bounces
Without any bounces?
Ready?
Yeah!
This is impossible!
Maybe now you see
what that part of my racket
is for!
I feel scammed!
I feel absolutely
CHEATED!
Good luck Emil!
Ready?
Yea, I'm ready!
Let's see
if you can do better
That's it!
Otto has one point
I have one point
Miikka is still at zero
But
maybe the next challenge is yours?
We are gonna have
a beauty contest!
I like the idea!
We made an Instagram poll
for you guys to vote
for the most beautiful racket
And at the end of the episode
we will see
which one you chose
as the prettiest one!
Make sure to watch
until the end of the video
to see the results of the poll!
Lassi
Your challenge!
So you all have
your own half of a table
And who gets
three points first, wins!
A match to three points
on a triangle table!
Quite simple!
The golden racket to the win!
You have turned on the light effect!
I got it!
It's really fast!
Lightsaber
is coming into play!
Second point to Emil
Chance to win the game
Good serve Otto!
Faster serve!
Really good serve
YEEESS!
No, he won it!
I won!
But now we are even!
1-1-1
That's actually true!
So the poll!
It's down to the beauty contest!
Results are in!
Will money count?
With
18%
18 percent?
That's been quite tight!
Contestant...
A:
Otto's chair!
Lightsaber against diamond gold!
The most beautiful
racket
ever made by
the Pongfinity guys!
Winner of the
whole tournament
is...
with
forty-
forty-one
%
41%?
It's a tie game!
Are you kidding me?
Wow!
41-41-18!
That's crazy!
Both are equally amazing!
This was so much fun!
If you enjoyed this video
Make sure to subscribe!